I've drawn a small illustration I feel
hey man it's an instinct to think you do
might turn up and I take my gosh you
look so like Michael Jackson I go I
think it looks quite cozy being a smooth
yeah looks like a funnel it like they
don't like each other and they're all
happy and you know smooth that's pretty
hot right this what I was thinking come
on I said a movie with John Nelson I'm
just gonna show and when I did you yeah
so I saw I think he's gone for breakfast
up for me yeah it's leave all my
favorite movies I've seen there 25 times
final film in the movie
I got chicken nuggets sweet-and-sour
sauce and a chocolate sundae please so
there's a new Wolverine day this year
the good is very gonna look pretty
different than I don't is why the same
bolt lives on couple rate by roof oh wow
so I used to watch my little sister yeah
My Little Pony My Little Pony this is
going bar already
I see you so good at drawing I actually
thought I was getting better rubbish
this is cozy Malawi County pitch you
still pretty cool I think et I think et
would be endearing whereas mr. t he's
like yeah you might you know nah Mar the
overall kind of he's a pretty brash guy
right
smash former yeah looking at Oh No is
there anything more depressing they're
broken IKEA coffee table now cuz that's
all I've known cuz I've never really
successfully put something together
right